Christophe Ripert alias Luke dans
premiers baisers a fait rêver des
millions de jeunes filles en France dans
les années 90 tenez-vous bien ça y est
vous avez devant vous la future star du
Top 50 sur fond sur le succès de la
série Christophe Rippert est bien devenu
à l'instar de son personnage une star du
Top 50 en sortant plusieurs albums et
quelques tubes comme un amour de
vacances en 1993 c'est un
une histoire
et au début des années 2000 le succès a
fini par s'effriter ça a été un choc le
choc Anne-Laure site bon la connu en
2002 en pénétrant dans le château de la
Star Academy lors de la saison 2
à l'époque la jeune femme crève l'écran
et a même atteint la finale du mythique
télé crochet de TF1
[Musique]
après avoir menu de carrière solo dans
les années 2000 la jeune femme a fini
par retourner à ses premiers amours le
tennis ancienne joueuse de haut niveau
elle est aujourd'hui côte alors que
Christophe Rippert a quant à lui créer
une agence de création digitale pour les
marques de luxe les reconversions
inévitables mais réussi alors quelle vie
après avoir été une star de la télé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous jure je vais à la Plaine
Saint-Denis je passe le casting il sort
devant moi et moi j'ai passé le casting
pour essayer d'avoir un rôle j'ai passé
deux fois le casting ah c'est triste les
deux fois et j'avais dit à mon père
j'arrête le droit j'arrête tout ça et je
suis Robert De Niro c'est bon ce que
premier ils m'ont dit tu reviens et je
l'ai jamais eu et je suis reparti et je
voyais Christophe partir c'est pourquoi
il a tout
il joue au tennis 15-2 je suis une
quiche il fait premier baiser je suis en
fac de droit je suis nul et il est beau
il est riche il chante il fait la
première partie de Hélène Rollès merde
pourquoi tout et la vie m'a rendu un
petit peu puisque aujourd'hui je
t'appelle au téléphone j'ai ton
téléphone absolument je tiens à préciser
que tu n'étais pas c'était pas cette
semaine que tu déjeunires ont eu des
changements je t'ai appelé
personnellement je dis est-ce que tu
peux bouger ton emploi du temps et tu
m'as dit oui ça me touche beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci merci pour l'invitation
on va parler de ta vie parce que c'est
elle a complètement changé maintenant
c'est Hélène mask je vous le dis ah
ouais ah bah les gars avant il était
beau et beau maintenant il est beau et
riche donc maintenant je requis de Cyril
et Grégory maintenant j'attaque monsieur
et à côté à Nord alors à Nord qui a fait
la Star Ac qui sent très bien qui
t'arrête loin de la Star Ac et tu es
aussi mythique parce que on avait jamais
vu ça en fait et c'était tout jeune et
on avait jamais vu ça depuis Amélie
Mauresmo tu as été je crois la première
fille alors tu nous diras si c'est la
prod qui te l'a demandé ou pas je vais
pas dire annoncé on dirait parce que
c'est c'est pas mal ton homosexualité
dans dans cette émission donc pour ta
jeunesse elle a été quand même tu vois
quand tu fais les zénithes et que tu
annonces que tu es gay à la France
entière à 18 ans tu as des nuits
difficiles j'imagine
j'étais poussée par tout un mouvement
c'était un moment où je pense
franchement qu'on était des milliers
de jeunes femmes à avoir besoin de c'est
la prod qui te l'a demandé ou pas du
tout pas du tout non non non c'était
hyper naturel j'ai eu des discussions à
l'époque avec avec les profs avec le
l'attaché de 13 de TF1 mais c'est venu
de moi et personne ne m'a poussé alors
ça te dérange si on commence par parce
qu'on ne referme
et en plus c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup
bonjour Benoît bonjour merci de
m'accueillir je m'appelle Mathieu
Delormeau j'ai 48 ans je suis gay
bonjour Mathieu
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Jean-Mi j'ai 61 ans je suis
polyamour bonjour
je m'appelle Natacha mâle je dirais pas
mon âge et je suis un homme je vais
faire l'amour
voici ma perruque tout est dit
alors on va parler de vous à Nord Star
Academy vous avez 18 ans j'ai 19 ans 19
ans gamine vous arrivez dans la Star Ac
vous êtes un petit peu différente des
autres parce que très sportive tout ça
vous chantez très bien vous avez fait
des duos avec enfin c'est magique vous
arrivez très loin je crois demi-finale à
peu près entre demi-finale en
demi-finale voilà et puis là ensuite
derrière c'est la tournée vous faites
des Zéniths des Zéniths vous dites un
jour dans un reportages c'est incroyable
j'ai fait la vie à l'envers parce que
j'ai commencé dans des Zéniths et puis
ensuite j'ai fini dans les salles où il
y avait 40 personnes parce que la suite
on la connaît vous faites des albums et
puis la vie c'est pas toujours facile
les albums marchent un peu moins c'est
ça ah oui la musique est très difficile
et avant d'avoir un projet qui
fonctionne c'est pas faut être l'élu
faut avoir une chance je pense que
et plus on avance plus on se dit on
regarde derrière on se dit j'ai quand
même vécu un truc de dingue au moment de
la Star Ac c'était jamais je crois voilà
jamais je crois que dépression derrière
quand tout d'un coup on vend 40 000
disques et que ça s'arrête ou pas tu
peux pas tu peux pas ne pas avoir de
coup de blues quand tout était dans une
forêt ou tu vis des moments incroyables
tous les jours mais quand tu l'as pues
et quand tu l'as plus évidemment que tu
as un coup de blues là c'est humain
c'est naturel c'est normal et la seule
chose qui fait que tu restes
sur terre c'est ton éducation ta famille
tes valeurs et puis de bosser et puis
retravailler
tu travailles et puis c'est tout et
alors vous rencontrez l'amour oui
je fais un documentaire sur vous en 2020
en 2020 vous habitez dans le sud de la
France vous m'expliquez à ce moment-là
vous avez totalement changé de métier
vous étiez vous avez ouvert une école de
tennis ce que vous jouez très bien au
tennis
alors on est en 2023 aujourd'hui et j'ai
annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux qu'il ne
faut plus lire et puis regarder c'est ça
on s'est malheureusement quitté quand je
vous ai tourné vous m'avez dit est-ce
qu'on peut retourner la série où on
s'est rencontré pour se redire que c'est
l'amour à vie et se redire que quand tu
as la bonne personne et cette séquence
était presque j'ai de la rentrée parce
qu'elle était tellement intime vous vous
embrassiez c'était très très beau alors
quand vous m'avez dit ça au téléphone
le lien il était très fort il est
toujours très fort et je
crois que
j'aurais jamais pu imaginer que que la
vie m'amène ailleurs parce que ça a été
ma décision je peux vous poser une
question intime c'est parce que vous en
rencontrer quelqu'un d'autre oui
d'accord et
c'est arrivé comme ça l'amour a un quand
ça tombe dessus et pourtant je me
pensais super heureuse très bien j'avais
la maison de mes rêves une vie qui
m'allait et
ça a été plus fort que tout l'amour m'a
emmené ailleurs et aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui dans la même ville ou pas du
tout non je vis près de Montpellier près
de Montpellier avec cette femme oui tout
à fait déjà vous allez vite vous on est
ensemble on va en général très vite les
couples de femmes en général ça va très
bien vous avez dit aucune corrélation
entre le temps les gens qui disent
j'attends 20 ans pour me marier ou trois
mois c'est pas pour ça qu'il y a du rond
plus on n'est pas marié mais on est
inséparable
mais en fait
c'est pas la c'est pas la longueur c'est
pas le temps qui compte c'est la
passion c'est ce qu'on vit c'est
l'instant présent et puis et puis
on en parlait avec Christophe juste
avant on est en paix aujourd'hui avec
Olivia avec mon ex on est en paix elle
va bien elle a rencontré quelqu'un elle
est très heureuse et moi c'est marrant
je depuis que je sais qu'elle va bien
sûr
après aussi mais les gens qui comme vous
ont connu ce qu'on appelle un peu des
vies de shoot comme ça vous avez
systématiquement besoin d'un projet
amoureux de quelque chose mais vous
pouvez pas avoir une vie assez plate
pardon parce que vous n'avez pas été
fait pour ça mais on va arriver à
Christophe dans un instant ce qu'il a
fait c'est vraiment je te dis c'est
exceptionnel parce que j'aurais pas su
faire après cette étude en finance c'est
de te dire si tu sais louer merci papa
qu'elle essaie de Mercedes pour mes
études et aujourd'hui vous avez
totalement changé de vie aujourd'hui
j'ai plusieurs que vous faites j'ai
plusieurs casquettes je fais du coaching
à l'entreprise ça c'est quelque chose
que j'ai toujours fait que continue à
faire donc je demande des événements
privés pour des pour des entreprises je
continue à faire des concerts à chanter
de temps en temps et puis surtout je
suis club je suis
j'ai commencé par ça et aujourd'hui
j'avais 25 ans après j'ai été
coordinatrice j'ai géré jusqu'à 7 hôtels
cette équipe d'animation et puis
maintenant je m'occupe de la partie
événementiel pour un club dans le sud de
la France et c'est c'est ma place et
c'est votre place et vous êtes heureuse
aujourd'hui ah ouais je suis bien
là-dedans c'est c'est mon laboratoire je
crée je produis je me lève le matin je
me dis tiens j'ai une idée ce soir faire
ça sur scène devant moi j'ai des gens
qui arrivent d'Allemagne de Hollande de
France de Belgique j'ai des familles le
but du jeu c'est de leur faire passer
des meilleures vacances possible on
s'éclate je suis jamais fatigué donc
c'était de montrer que quand les choses
s'arrêtent on a vu pour les bosses
blondes Franck delette tout ça quand les
choses s'arrêtent et parfois plutôt que
de s'accrocher tout d'un coup et des
petites pièces de théâtre ou pour
essayer d'exister encore essayer de
faire quelque chose d'autre parce qu'on
a toujours du talent en soi mais on perd
confiance en soi quand les choses vont
moins bien essayer d'en trouver vous
l'avez trouvé vous avez changé de vie
vous êtes heureuse et tout marche bien
2023 bébé c'est ton année merci beaucoup
en face de là
maintenant on s'intéresse à mon mec
comme on dit au Québec mon tchami
Christophe
je ne sais pas pourquoi il y a rien non
mais il a l'air vraiment non
je rigole
tu fais premier baiser tu exploses tu es
lu Siri
tu es le beau gosse c'est celui qui a le
plus beau couple tu on te voit dans tous
les épisodes j'en ai parlé avec
à l'époque qui ne voulait pas au départ
qui te voulait pas il te voulait pas au
départ au départ je fais le casting
c'est très marrant je fais le casting
grâce à Aude qui me dit que tu viens à
la Plaine Saint-Denis pour moi c'était
nouveau ça me faisait quitter Tolbiac
quand on arrive à Tolbiac on se dit
c'est une activité de d'économie dans
Paris
j'ai fait j'ai fait trois mois et quand
tu faut vraiment être motivé je j'ai
vraiment les élèves ont du mérite de
travailler dans des conditions comme ça
je trouve quand tu arrives dans milieu
c'est horrible et 800 dans un
environnementités aux États-Unis dans
les dans les séries quand tu as la
chance d'y aller tu dis le c'est pas le
même alors attends bébé
je dis que c'est important enfin moi
j'arrive là-bas et vous savez ça m'évite
d'aller à Tolbiac j'arrive au de mes
séances qui me fait passer le casting
j'ai envie que je dis non il y a trop
effet féminé avec sa mèche son bordel ça
marchera jamais donc ma belle elle me
dit écoute Jean-Luc tu veux pas mais
reviens quand même on va insister et
Jean-Luc me donne le rôle au départ tu
voulais peut-être remarqué ceux qui s'en
souviennent parce que c'est quand même
il y a 30 ans mais au flipper enfin il
me prend vraiment pour faire plaisir
pour faire plaisir pour faire plaisir à
Maud il s'en fout en fait et au fur et à
mesure on avait recevait le courrier à
l'époque effectivement j'étais celui qui
a reçu pas mal de courrier puis de plus
en plus de courrier et Jean-Luc m'a fait
m'a donné une phrase de phrase et puis
ainsi de suite et c'était à monter ça
monte ça monte pendant des années là tu
deviens une énorme star enfin si pardon
tu ne dis pas toi mais je peux te le
dire
donc tout le monde te connaît tu
travailles du matin au soir on s'amuse
l'argent rentre j'imagine que comme tous
les gamins que tu es bah ça s'achète des
Porsche et ça déconne entre autres entre
autres j'aurais fait parler à ta place
est-ce à ce moment-là tu mets de
l'argent de côté tu as conscience que ça
peut s'arrêter tu es un peu ou tu es fou
fou alors non on n'a pas conscience que
ça peut s'arrêter d'abord parce que ça
voilà c'était pris dans une espèce de
frénésie comme ça ça marche les
audiences sont là Jean-Luc te dit c'est
super continuez Patrick le lait et va
être une mojote nous à peine une fois
par an pour faire
les enfants on va continuer les
l'audience et le public est au
rendez-vous puis après enchaîne la
musique donc la musique avec les
tournées et autres donc c'est pris dans
un espèce de spirale et tu dis bah c'est
fantastique c'est payé pour t'amuser
t'aimer les gens t'apprécientes ce qui
est génial Christophe c'est que tous les
autres et je leur en veux pas je les
adore tous Patrick puydebay et tout ce
que vous avez vu sont aujourd'hui dans
toutes les séries d’abais sur TMC Benoît
et dedans et vivre de ça depuis 30 ans
et il y en a un qui pour chaque année
mais qui a fait autre chose est-ce que
tu peux nous dire ce que tu as fait
parce que moi je t'ai tourné j'étais
filmé tu as monté une start-up non il y
a 20 ans en fait effectivement quand on
quand on quitte et quand on est ce
comédien là faut savoir qu'il y a je
vais revenir un peu dans le passé mais
il y a 33 ans la télévision et cinéma
ces deux demandes différentes ce n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui il y a vraiment
il y a des passerelles et puis un peu
ah bon bah ouais
je peux vous le dire
moi qu'avant et grâce aux plateformes
et donc moi ce qui me plaisait après
j'aurais aimé j'avais Guy bonnet à
l'époque qui était un super agent chez
agent associé qui est je disais écoute
tu mets figurant dans dans des films tu
veux juste figurants
c'est très compliqué
c'était pas possible je me suis dit
mince dépend du désir de l'autre et
attendre que le téléphone sonne pour
faire des castings et te dire c'est tout
c'est pas toi non c'est pas toi parce
qu'on connaît déjà on j'habite à tête et
trop con je me suis dit c'est pas
possible je veux que ma vie dépende de
moi et j'ai monté mon agence il y a 20
ans mon agence on agence de
communication digitale d'autre part de
la prod qui est devenu après qui a pris
le virage du digital qui s'appelle happy
end parce que je voulais faire du cinéma
je me suis dit comme j'ai ma boîte c'est
moi qui décide je fais mais je propose
des projets je vais jouer dedans et puis
je vais les produire et puis bon
c'est pas passé comme ça la vie on a
décidé autrement j'ai travaillé pour les
marques et les marques de luxe et j'ai
eu la chance de travailler pour Dior
pendant 18 ans pour quartier pendant 10
ans pour boucherie aujourd'hui j'avais
35 salariés à l'époque aujourd'hui j'en
ai 10 j'avais 35 salariés pendant 15 ans
Dior était faisait l'essentiel
l'essentiel de mon chiffre d'affaires
c'était énorme puisqu'on faisait les
films corporelles je suis méchants
on faisait 2 millions et demi par an de
déjà faire chiffre d'affaires
régulièrement et ça pendant 20 ans Dior
était le client principal et et quand
Dieu a décidé d'internaliser comme ça
arrive souvent dans les boîtes une
stratégie de groupe de dire bon externe
Élise on était analyse on a arrêté la
collaboration du 18 ans et en parallèle
j'avais monté effectivement ma start-up
mon logiciel un logiciel qui allait
permettre parce que j'avais identifié
des non non
pas ce que j'aimerais je rêve de pouvoir
avoir les moyens de pouvoir faire des
choses avec ce qu'il a comme argent à
disposition mais en tout cas déjà de
faire des choses qui me plaisent qui te
font sens qui apporte vraiment du qui
qui réponde un vrai besoin métier mon
logiciel s'appelle Hero c'est une
solution très simple quand on travaille
dans la prod il y a des producteurs ici
autour de la table je le sais on
travaille avec beaucoup d'outils avec
beaucoup d'intervenants avec beaucoup de
freelance avec beaucoup de prestataires
et après on en anglais parce que nous on
est perdu depuis tout à l'heure il y a
beaucoup de mots d'anglais
de toute façon je savais que j'allais
faire chier tout le monde avec
énormément
10 secondes ça sert simple c'est un
outil de gestion collaboratif ça permet
de faciliter les les workflow de
production les process de production
j'adore on a un bidou
tu gagnes très bien ta vie je pense je
gagne bien ma vie tu l'avais dit de mon
documentaire donc tu peux le dire ou pas
ma vie et j'espère la gagner encore
mieux si ma start-up fonctionne ouais et
réussit et finalement trouve le trouble
l'audience et le succès qui l'attaque
chaque année à zoulette appelle pour
revenir dans les mystères de l'amour
Jean-Luc est un jalus c'est mon papa
artistique mais parce qu'en fait
j'expliquais ça dans les loges il y a
pas de caméra
en fait j'aurais l'impression de faire
la même chose que j'ai fait il y a il y
a 30 ans avec tellement de bonheur et
avec toutes ces établissements ce qui
est autour ce que j'aime moi c'est faire
des choses nouvelles c'est aller vers
l'inconnu je pense qu'on est des
explorateurs moi ce qui me plaît c'est
de pouvoir aller non mais c'est de
pouvoir aller vers ce que je ne connais
pas
non mais production je connais pas
j'ai une dernière question à vous poser
et à la et à l'autre en vrai quand même
malgré tout
connu c'est un kit est-ce que ça vous
manque pas un petit peu la lumière mais
il s'en fout complètement
doré être j'ai adoré la lune de temps en
temps j'aime bien de temps en temps
monter sur scène ou ou ou être sur un
plateau ou mais parce que ça fait vibrer
parce que il y a une énergie il y a une
intensité c'est chouette comme on voit
derrière il y a quelque chose de mal et
surtout je suis tellement je suis
vraiment heureux dans ce que je fais
avec la vraie ambition de pouvoir aller
au bout de ce projet là et je peux vous
dire où il aurait fait un beau cadeau
parce que parce que c'est vrai que le
public pardon mais vous a tout donné ah
oui quand vous êtes aujourd'hui et l'un
et l'autre vous n'avez absolument rien à
vendre aucune promo et vous m'avez dit
au téléphone et c'est très mignon il m'a
tout donné je vais faire Montpellier
Paris pour leur rendre un petit peu si
ça leur fait plaisir ça s'appelle la
générosité je vous souhaite le meilleur
pour demain
[Applaudissements]